my guest tonight is a very talented
actor who has starred in rogue one a
star wars story and narcos mexico
now you can see him in the film wander
darkly
which is available on demand it's a very
beautiful and haunting film please
welcome our friend
diego luna hey diego how are you
i'm very good how are you i'm doing okay
uh how are you handling this whole zoom
thing because i've had the privilege of
speaking to you
many times in person you're great
conversationalist you're very funny
how do you feel like it's working for
you on zoom
oh it's uh it's tough tough to accept
this is the way
you know but uh but i'm doing it there's
there's good things about it i'm not
intimidated by your
height you know um
that is that is nice
same size on the frame you know i do my
own camera
i don't have your people you know
boycotting me
at all but uh you also
when we've talked in the past you do
comment on my giant head
and how it it it's unsettling to you it
must be nice now to see my head in a
more
normal way definitely definitely it is
it is it brings me peace uh and
i don't know i get very anxious and
nervous be before
going on a talk show with you and and
it's uh
it's nice to be on zoom you know i can
blame the connection
i don't speak english the way you do
it's my i mean
it's not the language i grew up with so
i have to pretend i understand every
joke you make
you know when i'm with you and now i can
just say like oh sorry what was that oh
my connection
[Laughter]
so you're blaming it all on your wi-fi
the fact that you
that you don't like my jokes okay no i
like them i mean they seem funny people
seem to laugh it's just that i don't get
them
[Laughter]
well that's apparently true for many
americans uh as well
you know we always have a tradition
whenever we're together we drink mezcal
together and we didn't want that to get
in the way just because i think you're
in london right now
i am and you're uh working on a very
top-secret project
and i'm here in los angeles i i don't
know about you i brought some mezcal
i'm going to have a shot of mezcal do
you have mescal with you
always i mean always okay
you carry it with you i say we do a shot
right now i hope your your glass is the
the
the right glass for mezcal you know it
has to be um
you said it has to be short yeah two
years stop
okay i'm gonna go smaller than that uh
it's early here it's night time for you
it is nighttime for me it's like the
morning for you
uh but i guess you drink every morning
right so yes you would assume that
that's what the irish do
um listen uh i want to say uh diego
here's to you
uh is familia uh
and uh gente de mexico all the people of
mexico
salud salud do it let's do it
oh ah wow
you did it the the american way yeah
yeah
you can just sleep it i mean you have a
long show
i mean you don't have to just go for it
i thought it was supposed to go for it
no no not at all not mexican then buy
cheap
cheap tequila or something else it's
burning it's burning my lungs and my
chest right now
[Laughter]
oh my god i thought oh you're just
skipping it yeah you gotta slip it i i
want to make another toast
if you don't mind and i i guess you
don't you already
know okay here we go here's another
toast another toast for the new win of
joe biden today yes yes the winner of
joe biden today i will toast to that too
yeah oh
holy crap oh this interview is gonna be
are you okay it burns it burns
and it's the second one shouldn't burn
but you're drinking like you know like a
spring breaker
relax i mean i could sip it as what
you're saying
i i forgot eight years for the plant to
grow and you just have it in a second
like i know i'm disrespecting the mezcal
i don't mean to
yeah and you're talking about are we
talking about
diego where are you what were we talking
about
i know what i want to talk oh there you
are i want to talk about this
you're filming in london this star wars
series uh and or it's a secret project
you're not supposed to talk at all but
now that you're having mezcal
maybe you'll tell us some things
that's why i see that man i mean i go
sit by seat because
i know it's dangerous to be in your show
no i can't i cannot talk
you're not allowed to talk i'm not
allowed to talk you know i can
we can do mimi i can tell you the whole
story and like come on
diego what happens
in endor i can tell you
it's a show okay well people are very ex
people are very excited about it
and um they're probably because you like
to talk
they might they might think you're a bit
of a risk because you're a talker you
know
you're a guy that likes to you know yeah
what you're up to are they worried that
you're going to blab something about and
or that you shouldn't
i'm sure they they are i'm sure they are
there's nothing they can
do uh you know uh they cannot restrict
my access to zoom
uh you know they did a lockdown in
london for me to stay at home
uh you know they're closing bars and
restaurants tomorrow and it's not gonna
be enough right
no i assume yeah i'm getting good at not
not saying
you know the everyone knows the ending
now right so
it's not that i can tell you oh i died
you know it's like
so it's over right right right everyone
i'm sure
people are very excited about it and i
know that you're working in london
you've also spent a lot of quarantine or
pandemic
in mexico city tell me what it's like
there
i got to talk to you in mexico city once
i love mexico city
but it is such a large such a densely
populated city
i would think uh a pandemic in mexico
would be very frightening you know just
and and the way that people have to
respond to it
is very serious yeah it was hardcore at
the beginning
i mean obviously it's a country with all
this contrast
as you as you witness yeah and uh and
there's
a lot of people just surviving you know
you know and staying home is not an
option
uh and the lack of state you know the
reach of the state
also uh uh is not what you would expect
in in a moment like this
so it was it was beautiful to see all
these
reactions you know of citizens helping
others you know understanding that the
conditions were different for each other
i guess the pandemic just came to show
you know
how deep an equality is and how much we
have to work in in
trying to bring the polls together
it was it was difficult because he got
there late you know i was coming back
from london
and uh in my family we got it pretty
soon not myself but my son and my
daughter
and i had to deal with the issue before
it was an issue in mexico
right and it's been long and it's been
painful and difficult
and uh and and i don't know i mean
it's uh this these moments bring the
best out of people and that's what i
want to focus on you know yeah that's
good it it can it's brought the worst
out of some people as well
unfortunately uh we've seen that in our
country but
many people have reacted well and i know
that some people say well they've just
binge watched a lot of television
and drank a lot of wine in in in to get
through
the the pandemic but that wasn't really
an option for a lot of people
in mexico well no i mean honestly
and and this is th this is like i i
couldn't
watch like more than five minutes of
anything without getting distracted how
could you you know
the world was changing this huge lens
once
was on top of us to show us what we had
to work on how can you plug yourself
into the tv you know
yeah i don't know if like i don't know i
couldn't watch a single
tv series you know right you're
supporting your family i don't know
unless you're money laundering i guess
you can watch a whole uh
you know people you're right if who has
the
you know it's it's a luxury people don't
realize it's so luxury to not have to do
any work to not have to do anything and
just binge watch
i managed to binge watch all of my shows
since 1993. that's all i did oh very
smart
i watched my i watched myself i watched
thousands and thousands of hours of me
and i saw myself get older and my face
get fatter i just over a long period of
time
and and it didn't get your show any
better to be honest no no no it's
now wait a minute come on okay
dude cool that's just
true it is true but i wonder like these
people that are just
sharing oh i saw this and i saw that and
i saw the whole crown and i saw all
these and that like who's raising their
kids
yeah uh
it's been it's been hardcore they just
confronted me with my ignorance you know
i had to go again through
really basic um i'm gonna
i'm curious you're uh i know that you're
in london now
are you going to celebrate christmas in
london or
mexico city no i mean i i have to
pretend i love
being in london in winter but no one
saying can
actually say that you know it's painful
it's
i mean it's a beautiful city to watch
from your window but uh it gets really
cold and wet
uh at least for for a mexican is it's
not probably the best so i'm flying back
home
as soon as we finish uh uh to spend the
holidays
not just that it's not just the weather
uh
you know my family is there i want to be
with this pandemic it's like
there's no time off i don't want to be
next to my kids my
dad my friends yeah yeah reminds you
what really matters you know
i'm told that's true i don't think it's
helped me know what matters
uh i'm as distant from my family as ever
um but i'm broken inside diego i'm
terribly broken inside
to be honest it's it's it's quite sad to
see you
with the christmas tree the lights there
and no audience man
it's like normally you have people who
are laughing about your jokes but
i know i know it's like a rewarding you
can play
a recording of laughter people used to
go
to your show i have some tapes of people
laughing at my jokes from 1996.
so i'll start playing those those and
all the people laughing are now
they've all died of old age so we'll be
coming from beyond the grave
um tell me about what it's like because
i would imagine
that the mexican people take christmas
very very seriously how seriously do
they take it in mexico city
i mean it's just another event uh and a
chance to
to drink mezcal and have fun no but
it is a very religious country and uh
and we take
we call it the marathon guadalupe you
know which
basically starts the 12th of december
that we celebrate the the
the the the virgin's day virgin of
guadalupe
and it goes all the way to january you
know so it's basically a drinking
contest
that doesn't stop and party after party
and
and everybody my birthday happens to be
just
just in between you know the 29th of
december oh nice
it's a it's a big holiday in mexico you
know
so you're basically saying you've never
been sober for your birthday
now and and i've i've always been alone
you know people are with their families
or hangover or getting ready for new
year's eve
or somewhere else but but with me yeah
so
there's no it's impossible for someone
in mexico city a true mexican
to not indulge on the holidays you just
have to
you just everyone has to everyone has to
like i i did a documentary film
on a fantastic mexican boxer called
julio cesar chavez the biggest champion
and uh and he said to me one day in the
in on an interview that uh the first
time he lost
it was because don king could put him to
fight in
the first weeks of january and he was
like you cannot do that
and the biggest record you know of the
unbeaten
champion 88 or 89 fights professional
fights
was broken because because he was coming
out of the party i mean you received is
new year's eve
come on no he lost his he had the
greatest record going in boxing
88 89 victories in a row but then
because he had to fight
in early january he lost just because he
had been partying
but but he says in the documentary i
told don king you know
he was even mad not at himself a donkey
for programming a fight in january
but not to himself that he couldn't stop
that
that year from going to the party and i
think we all understand that we go like
yeah i mean what was he thinking
yeah he fought that guy again like
weeks later and beated him in one round
he was clearly
so that's my new plan i'm going to
challenge mexico's greatest champion
and i want it to take place on january
1st and you think maybe i have a chance
of winning
don't challenge canelo because i think
he doesn't drink and
[Laughter]
okay well i won't do that who do you
choose
i want to say uh your beloved in your
country are you getting used to the fact
and this is true
that many people are naming their
children
after you that must how does that feel
i thought it was after me but then i
understood it was a
about maradona you know we have that we
shared the same name and it wasn't me
you know but i thought it was you no no
sadly not uh but there's many comments
there
and i you know and i just i mean i'm
sorry for those kids
when they why would you feel sorry for a
a
beautiful young mexican boy or girl
growing up with the name conan what a
proud heritage
yeah until they go onto youtube and find
out why
i mean
we're gonna see this video they're gonna
see the image of you with the bottle
like this that's everything they're
gonna have to see i'm a good role model
for all the children
[Laughter]
yeah there's uh no one's naming kids
after me it's not happening
but uh well let me talk to you about
your beautiful film wander
darkly uh i don't even want to try to
sum up this movie because it's about so
much
it's a very intense but beautiful movie
about this couple
and um and there's a lot of twists and
turns
and it's done very beautifully there's
some intense
scenes and there's a scene where and i
don't think i'm giving anything away
here because it
it could be a dream it could not be a
dream but there's a scene where
your character is put into a morgue
drawer and just seeing you just because
i know you and i know you're
an actor and you're acting in a role but
you get slid into one of those real
morgue drawers and it looked real and it
was very haunting
it felt real and uh it was real it's a
little independent movie it's not that
they built the place for me
you know we went into a
that's place real morgue yeah i mean i'm
sure they
i mean they took whoever lives there
out before i went in but uh but yeah i
went into the real thing and it was my
first day of shooting
i thought they were like trying to send
me a message you know he was like oh
welcome
we love to have you sit down here
lay down and then when they close that
thing man
the sound of that i mean i hope the next
time i hear it i'm dead
because it's uh it's horrible it's
horrendous it's like
and then is it lit in there like what is
it lit in there can you see
when they close them or what i mean why
would you put light in there
okay that's all right you're right
that's a stupid question
the dead person might want some good
lighting that's all they're in the
drawer
exactly it's saving saving light you
know like saving energy light obviously
oh my god that must have been a dramatic
experience
it was horrible and and then there was a
scene happening out there so they kept
me there while the scene was going
and then i could hear caught and then
time passed it felt like an eternity to
me it was
probably 10 15 seconds till someone
remember oh open it
and they got me out and i was like white
and going like
oh it was it was intense it was it was
just uh
i mean a great a reminder of what an
actor
has to be ready for you know yeah i
would think so
i would think so and also you're very
lucky they remembered
what if they just said let's go you know
it's time to eat
and they all left i mean you were lucky
i'm lucky then now that you say that it
was the first day of shooting and not
the last year
uh you could still be there now yeah
let me ask you you're you have very uh
your co-star in this film is sienna
miller
very beautiful very talented cnn miller
you two have a very good
um chemistry together you perform very
well together
uh does it help that you're friends in
real life you've known each other for a
long time
yeah definitely there was like a
chemistry that you
we lent to the characters yeah you can't
rehearse that i mean it takes
years to get that right and uh and we
were
trying to work together for quite a long
time and the script arrived and it was
a fantastic opportunity because it's a
through the force i mean what she does
is
incredible uh i urge people to watch it
because she's fantastic in the film
and uh but it's a really tough i mean
job you know for for for an actor and it
was beautiful to live the experience
with someone i admire i care and i like
well you and i have been friends now for
i want to say at least five years so i
think it's inevitable that
we will be in a film together we have
such great chemistry
i i i can't wait for that uh
i can't wait for that no really i am
honest i am honest
good i don't know what's going on in
spanish because i know your spanish is
really good
you have to build a new audience since
now you don't have an audience there
i'm going to start an american market
yes i'm going to start i'm going to just
oh my show now i'm just going to only
work uh i'm gonna try and just win over
mexico i'm gonna work very hard to win
over the people of mexico
you know forget america it's it's time
just for me to focus on mexico
and and the good thing is you can stay
in america because there's more than 30
million people there from mexico trust
me i said i see them all the time i live
in los angeles
you know they're they're holding the
whole state together
well listen this is a an absolute
delight to see you make sure i mention
wander darkly to beautiful film is now
on demand on apple tv prime video
or wherever you get your movies
uh diego i salute you yet again
trust me i don't even think it's noon
here yet
but salud
thank you very much uh it's it's a
pleasure always to be in your show
a good mezcal because tomorrow you might
be having some headache
yeah i'm gonna i have the headache now
this
[Laughter]
with your big head that must be
with my big head a headache is fatal uh
diego luna i bow to you you're a master
thank you very much and be well
thank you thank you